farid have we finally reached the
post-american world you wrote about a
decade ago well you know what I was
writing about in that book was the the
post American world because you had
China rising you had India rising you
had Europe that had come together the
point I was trying to make was we're in
a kind of historical shift of power
where these other countries often that
had long been mired in poverty arising
in economic growth political power
cultural confidence and so that world
has been going on you know the emerging
markets were 5% of global GDP 25 years
ago they enough 50% of global GDP but
what I did not predict was that the
United States would sort of abdicate
leadership of its position because I
argued the United States would still be
incredibly powerful it would set the
agenda it represented you know the
values it had a way of being able to be
the leader and this shift where the
United States has decided to literally
just walk away from its own creation I
mean people forget this was the world
that FDR and Harry Truman built after
World War two and to see you know the
Europeans as I say sort of surprised
because they don't quite understand it
they're like wait you built this house
and now you want to set it on fire I'm
less surprised that a Trump could rise I
mean that has happen in countries were
as how quickly the Republican Party just
completely got behind him it reminds me
of the Neanderthals you know no no
really if you I love ancient the
archeology and that kind of stuff so
like you have the humans and the
Neanderthals who are sharing a planet
from about a hundred thousand BC to
about forty thousand BC and then
suddenly no more Neanderthals well I
think because humans they figured out
the blowgun so they could kill you from
10 feet away I'm getting this from the
movie quest for fire
but I think so but like it's like
there's Neanderthals and then suddenly
the foss gone and that's kind of what
happened to the Republicans I think it
we're just there and then they suddenly
decide what happened is and this is you
guessed it when Linda was asking what
happened to my party I think that Trump
recognized and the primaries you see
this that the Republican Party was in a
completely different place than the
elites in Washington thought the elites
in Washington was still repeatedly
reciting the Reagan formula free-trade
expansionist foreign policy entitlement
reform the base of the party is now a
white working-class base that wants to
hear about Mexicans Muslims and Chinese
people they want to hear about how the
the the Mexicans are taking your jobs
the Chinese people are saying your
factories the Muslims are killing you
Trump says I'll beat them all up
you'll be great again I mean the fact is
there were like 16 Republicans running
in the primaries and Trump didn't he did
not get a majority of Republican support
during the primaries he got a you know a
plurality and he won and he won in a lot
of places but the fact that it was so
divided the fact that the party had no
discipline whatsoever I mean I'd sort of
like to bring back the smoke-filled
rooms let's have them you know vetting
of people right before they decide to
run for president
[Applause]
Trump did as a political matter I mean
whether you want a rally or not he had
16 opponents many of them governor
Sanders well yeah and he just
slaughtered them all one by one without
really any impediment anything holding
you back and now and now I think the
more relevant point the bills making is
today would the never Trump rump is
diminished dwindle to almost nothing
yeah but you've got this incredibly high
historic as I said before historic level
of support among Republicans and no one
even though you can at least the
beginning of the administration you look
to people like Paul Ryan and Mitch
McConnell and said well they're going
along with Trump to get their agenda
done well they got their tax cut and now
today they're still
people spend time writing these
questions that's good this is for you
you're Michael you said you could be you
said you can be a minority and a
conservative but can you be a minority
and a Republican under this
administration you know that's a good
question I think that the expectation at
least from what I get from talking to
other african-americans and minorities
in general is that sure we don't have a
problem with you being a Republican but
our expectation is that you are
articulating the concerns of our
community so yes I'm a I'm a black
person who happens to be a Republican
that doesn't mean I don't care about
police brutality that doesn't mean I
don't care about criminal justice reform
those are issues that disproportionately
impact my community and it is my duty if
you will when I'm at that table when I'm
in those meetings to advocate for the
issues of my community because I
recognize there will be moments like the
moment we see now where you have a Jeff
Sessions running the criminal justice
system and he's rolling back a lot of
things that President Obama did with
bipartisan support that benefited
African Americans so it is my charge to
say wait a minute here you're not going
to pass policy legislation that's going
to continue to disproportionately impact
not only black people but brown people
so I think you can most certainly be a
conservative and a minority but being a
Republican right now into an age of
Trump I think is a very difficult thing
sure Michael happens to be one of my
favorite Republicans because what we've
seen is a lack of you a pretty short
list you know y'all taking all my good
lines but the thing is is that if you
have black people who understand even if
you're associated with that
administration that what Trump is doing
is undercutting the value of not only
black people but Republicans as we've
been saying and the fact that you had
William Coleman the fact that you had a
legacy of black people Jackie Robinson
for that matter who were Republicans who
understood that it was about an economic
orientation of fiscal conservatism it
was not about the culture wars that
Trump seems invested
because one of the factors we missed in
all of this brouhaha is the demonization
of the big black boogeyman Barack Obama
and that spooked a lot of people into
voting for the Republicans in a serious
way
I just associate I disassociate myself
as a black conservative with what we
call lily-white conservatism that sort
of wallows in racism if you will bigotry
sexism if you will and I think you have
to make a clear distinction between the
two and where the Republican Party go do
you do this I can understand how you
could do it when the Republican Party
was a party that was about economics and
free markets and free right now the
Republican Party is defined by its
suspicion and hostility toward people
who look different Sam different worship
different gods so what do you that's the
party how are you distinguished look for
read it you know President Trump talks a
lot about patriotism to the country when
we say the pledge of allegiance to the
flag we say one nation under God
indivisible eccentric says one nation
under God indivisible one nation
rhetoric or reality do we truly believe
we are one nation and if we are then
that means we recognize and we accept
that we are a country compounded of
different folks from all over the world
regardless of what they look like their
sex or their religion well that's not
how are your fellow Republican old Trump
certainly doesn't look at him all you
had to do is look at you know Hurricane
Maria and and look what happened in
Puerto Rico we've allowed him Linda
Taylor your invitation to the CPAC
convention get this at the gift shop
lady
you
[Applause]